vim
j'ai pris une formule initiale classique
celle que j'avais vécu pour mon père et
j'ai dépouiller le contraint en fait en
enlevant tout ce qui était facultatif
que des gadgets dans le choix du
cercueil c'est quelque chose de socx
aides versées en bois no en bois tendre
à la verse des bois noble ça peut être
du pain du sapin du peuplier qui
poussent vite et qu'ils sont se sont pas
trompés
pas de peinture etc des familles de
résine pour le corps par exemple il est
soit à l'aise de praxis qu'on l'ait soit
le conservation non obligatoire
d'ailleurs mais la plupart des gens ne
savent pas on allège les options et en
impact moi ça c'est mon mur ne fut ni
rêve c'est celle que j'ai choisie qui en
fait mieux recycler puisqu'elle a déjà
servi pour mon père j'ai fait le choix
de ne pas l'acheter lille avait utilisé
pas moins
ça c'est un modèle de sarkano un carton
c'est un des exemplaires qu'on propose
ça c'est le plus simple en cercueil en
carton brut depuis quatre ans qu'on
existe on a des demandes récurrentes de
familles qui veulent des obsèques plus
écologique et donc on a décidé de
proposer une vraie offre des cercueils
et des urnes en carton recyclés
fabriqués en france
ensuite on va également limiter l'usagé
des soins de conservation qui est en
fait font usage de produits chimiques
qui sont polluants et donc vont polluer
les sols et les nappes phréatiques
on va également résilié tous les contes
et les abonnements du défunt donc en
gros c'est pour limiter les échanges de
courriers papier ainsi que la
consommation électrique des serveurs et
dernier point qu'on vient de faire ce
qu'on a passé un partenariat avec un
pépiniériste français pour replanter un
arbre pour chaque famille qu'on a
accompagné
des demandes de beaucoup de parisiens on
nous disait voilà nous on est très
inquiets pour le devenir de la planète
on fait très attention dans notre vie
quotidienne à comment on mange on achète
on achète en vrac et on veut pouvoir
laisser le minimum d'empreinte
écologique à la fin de notre vie
ça s'inscrit dans tout ce qu'on a fait
sur les cimetières aujourd'hui où on a
décidé en 2015 d'arrêter les produits
phytosanitaires dans les cimetières de
travailler beaucoup sur arrêt
enherbement du cimetière sur la
revégétalisation sur la plantation
nouvelles espèces l'utilisation de
matériaux biodégradables cercueils aux
urnes
une stèle en bois en bois du nord de la
france n'est pas évidemment de bois
exotique puisque le cahier des charges
est assez précis là-dessus
alors on va aller voir les buts
on est métamorphosé donc en super
compost on aura de quoi rentrer fertile
l'espace pour faire pousser l'arbre pour
aller se recueillir
donc on a trouvé ben d'amour se bat sans
doute un des os des pattes sans doute de
de la brebis qui est des mises en
compostage depuis un peu moins de un peu
plus de monde ça va devenir donc après
12 mois on aura en fait du terreau sur
cinq il fallait qu'ils une femme qui ce
genre si demain il ya des tests mélanger
87 ans 84 ans plus tôt eh bien je serai
prêt à mettre mon corps est à
disposition et je crois que c'est une
solution nouvelle qui vous trouvez si on
veut que le monde puisse continuer à
fonctionner